[Música]
es el momento de nuestra revista de
prensa con Rosa Pérez a más de Buen día
para usted Rosa Buenos días Ángela vamos
a tener un tema que está bien grande el
día de hoy con diferentes perspectivas
de medios de comunicación hay revuelo
académico hay revuelo mediático e
incluso hasta artístico por la última
versión del llamado chat gpt un programa
de Inteligencia artificial que
básicamente nos puede reemplazar hasta
ustedes y yo nos podemos quedar sin
trabajo y es lo que ocupa la portada del
periódico francés lemont cuéntenos más
efectivamente Ángela está generando
mucha preocupación en distintos ámbitos
como usted bien lo decía y así lo titula
este periódico francés no la revolución
chat gpt y entre algunas de las pistas
no que nos da esta portada es Open ahí
la empresa digamos a fundadora de este
chat una startup conocida por este
programa capaz de escribir textos y
dialogar por escrito y ocupa un lugar
clave en el universo digital dice sus
creadores empujados por una visión m
abren perspectivas que plantean fuertes
cuestiones éticas y dentro de las
páginas en su versión digital
encontramos algunos de los ámbitos en
los que se plantean estas cuestiones
éticas tan importantes no como por
ejemplo alexandt escribe en la cabeza de
los creadores del chat gpt explica que
si bien la idea inicial era entre unos
cuantos pesos pesados de silicon Valley
entre los cuales se encontraba y lo más
crear una fundación para investigar en
Inteligencia artificial sin ánimo de
lucro Finalmente Open ahí ha acabado
siendo una empresa valorada en unos
29.000 millones de dólares y uno de los
principales inversores de esta empresa
es de hecho Microsoft en este artículo
encontramos el testimonio de alexey
greenbound físico filósofo y miembro del
comité nacional francés de ética que
asegura hace 20 años que no veíamos una
estructura con jóvenes ingenieros
desarrollando una tecnología tan
Revolucionaria la última vez fue
probablemente ser gaybrin y Larry page
con Google bien entre otras de las
implicaciones de los ámbitos en los que
encontramos pues revuelo no un poco de
debate es precisamente en el artístico
otra porque precisamente otro de los
planteamientos que encontramos en Lemon
es A quién pertenecen las imágenes y los
textos generados por una Inteligencia
artificial y es que esta misma empresa
tiene el programa Wally que genera
imágenes tal y como nosotros le pedimos
no con una breve descripción que las
genere por ejemplo lo que pasó y da Este
ejemplo el humor para que nos hagamos
cargo de este debate es que en este año
2022 el ganador del concurso de arte
digital de Colorado fue precisamente un
chico que realizó su obra con un
programa de Inteligencia artificial dice
esto abrió un debate enorme en el mundo
del arte sin embargo el debate no fue
tan animado en el mundo del derecho o
justamente de la propiedad intelectual
porque se Consideró que este chico pasó
80 horas describiendo a la Inteligencia
artificial como quería que fuera Esta
obra Finalmente y es que Ángela te doy
un ejemplo con mis amigos mientras
estábamos probando jugando con esta
Inteligencia artificial le pedimos que
dibujara que nos hiciera una imagen una
imagen de una rata voladora comiendo una
hamburguesa frente a la torre Eiffel
para pedir algo un poco difícil y nos
dibujó una paloma en lugar de una rata
voladora es decir que ser muy preciso a
la hora también de dar ciertas
indicaciones Bueno no es sorpresa con
todo lo que usted nos describe que los
medios de comunicación mantengan el tema
de conversaciones vigente empecemos con
el New York Times que dicen ahí pues el
New York Times nos plantea el debate en
el ámbito académico también un punto que
encontrábamos en Lemon que dice un
artículo escrito por Kylie young que
comienza de la siguiente manera mientras
revisaba exámenes de su curso de
religiones mundiales el mes pasado
Anthony aunman profesor de filosofía de
la Universidad del norte de Michigan
leyó el que consideró el mejor trabajo
de clase le preguntó al alumno no autora
de este trabajo que como lo había hecho
y el alumno le acabó reconociendo que
había utilizado este chat gtp no gpt
perdón y el profesor alarmado decidió
cambiar la forma en que impartía clase
pedir a los alumnos que hicieran los
borradores en la misma clase sin con un
acceso muy restringido a internet y
finalmente incorporar la Inteligencia
artificial también en el currículum
pidiendo a los alumnos que contrastaran
que analizarán las respuestas de la
máquina
es que es preocupante no no sabemos
Entonces qué va a ser de autoría Y qué
va a ser simplemente hecho por una
Inteligencia artificial el Time también
habla de ese tema que ha eclipsado
definitivamente el mundo académico y
pues en otros aspectos exactamente Y es
que una de las cuestiones que quedan
eclipsadas como dices cuando hablamos de
Inteligencia artificial es el importante
peso del trabajo humano que hay a la
hora de programar la Inteligencia
artificial en este caso lo que ha
revelado la revista Time es que Open ahí
con subcontrato de hecho a trabajadores
de Kenia de la empresa sama para que
corrigieran las respuestas tóxicas que
daba Este programa de Inteligencia
artificial y para que vetaran contenidos
pues violentos contenidos relativos a
abusos sexuales o a palabras digamos
malsonantes y lo que han revelado cuatro
trabajadores que han hablado en
condición de anonimato con la revista
Time es que han quedado traumatizados
por el contenido al que ha sido al que
han sido expuesto y todo esto por menos
de dos dólares la hora pues mire de esto
podríamos hablar horas de hecho se nos
queda un tema por fuera lastimosamente y
es una entrevista que la que le realizó
El diario de España a la máquina y que
fue publicada en internet así que
simplemente invitar a nuestros
televidentes a que la vean a usted
Gracias Rosa y vamos con el invitado del
día por supuesto Ángela esta mañana